make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with another episode of too
powerful for the MCU and this time we're
covering the annihilators now the
annihilators are probably the most
powerful team to ever exist in the
history of Marvel Comics if I'm being
honest with you guys like just all
around pound-for-pound the most powerful
team and the funny thing about it is I
think at it's at its peak it consisted
of like five or six people but like the
wholesale iteration of the annihilators
consisted of beta ray bill the Silver
Surfer icon who is a gallon Dorian space
knight basically just like a space robot
gladiator from the Shiar empire quasar
Wendell Vaughn and Ron and the accuser
this team was broken it was so
overpowered it wasn't even funny it was
so Opie Marvel created it and then
disbanded it within like the same story
because of like how do we tell stories
about this team like this this is
ridiculous like they had a short-lived
comic but there was no real way to tell
a story with a team like this that was
just so ridiculously overpowered to give
you guys some perspective on what this
team is capable of at any point in time
one or more of its members have been
shown to do the following things tear
apart black holes like crushed gravity
wells super-strength with no upper limit
basically it is keep beating stronger
and stronger like The Incredible Hulk
invulnerability they can take out
Hyperion in one shot we know that's a
big deal because Hyperion held two
universes apart they can to manipulate
cosmic energy they can manipulate life
energy they can tie and travel it can
create impenetrable force field and the
only people who can get past it are
people who can work reality they can
travel faster than light
they have cosmic awareness so they know
everything that's going on in the
universe at any particular point in time
they can make themselves intangible if
they have astral projection telepathy on
a universal scale meaning they could
read the minds of anybody no matter
where they are in the universe and they
have V on Omega level telekinesis to
give you a perspective of what that
means strife is a guy that has Omega
level telekinesis and he shook the moon
this team is ridiculously broken it's
nuts I don't understand like it's one of
these things where you just don't really
understand why they exist in the first
place right these guys are just so
incredibly ope and so the entire basis
behind the annihilators team came out
during the events of Thanos imperative
the team was formed by Cosmo the
cosmonaut dog right the the space dog
probably the coolest enemy they had was
the universal Church of Truth
they also had an enemy in the form of
like Thanos right lats are from the
negative zone they had some cool folks
but the idea was the team was composed
to be an extension of Star Wars
guardians of the galaxy right where
star-lord had himself Rocket Raccoon he
had Groot he had I want to say that it
was Drax a destroyer and it was it was
good more I know they were part of it I
don't think mantis was original was was
really part of the guardians of the
galaxy really like the original roster
was kind of funky until you got to the
release of the movie and then you
basically got businesses run and that
was the guardians from the film
basically all kind of thrown on to her
singular team the idea is that this team
was designed to be an extension of that
there were the guardians of the galaxy
war a relatively powerful team that they
really couldn't do it all right not even
remotely close to be honest I mean they
were woefully underpowered considering
most of the Universal threats that exist
out there and so Cosmo ended up creating
this team during the Thanos imperative
as an extension of that to be the heavy
hitters right so it's like the Avengers
and then like blue Marvel's multiversal
Avengers blue Marvel Captain Marvel
black panther spectrum who else was
there I think Connor Sims auntie man was
part of the team alone for do you want
to talk about broken do auntie man is so
broken it's it's ridiculous the guy
managed to take out the Mighty Avengers
like that like like literally when I say
take out the Mighty Avengers I mean like
the century in like Ares the God of War
right who's more or less on par with
Thor depending on who's riding the story
this guy overpowered that team and if
the fight had gone on any longer like
they would have died you know it was it
was nuts right he was it was it was
crazy he was really beefed up and then
he became a Herald of Galactus later on
do this guy managed to leave the
multiverse and enter XO space it was
nuts
Connor Sims was stupidly overpowered way
to do a video on him right like too
powerful for the MCU an t man thing I
was show up in the MCU and just like
that right like Thanos with the with the
Infinity Gauntlet and all that kind of
stuff Connor Sims would be like uh-huh
and then like that'd be the end of that
fight had that fight would be three
seconds long but it wouldn't it would
even be a contest but unless the
annihilators it was it was kind of crazy
right like with the annihilators and all
the power they had it was sort of nuts
because when you're talking about the
MCU is it's what we always talk about in
this series right like you're talking
about grounded characters you're talking
about characters and it's like the world
outside your window this team is so
wildly extreme there'd be no real
conceivable means of defeating them for
any of the Avengers the only way to make
it work would be for them to either get
the Infinity Gauntlet and even then it
probably wouldn't work or to bring in
somebody like Galactus right some
massive heavy hitter I mean here's
usually a port
understand when it comes to this team
overall I would say pound-for-pound
Silver Surfer is probably the most
powerful out of all of them he's a guy
who's more or less done it all right I
mean he's he's had all these wild
abilities and they've kind of waxed and
waned over the years but when you're
channeling the power cosmic which is
just a plot device or why Galactus can
just do the crazy things that he can
then there really is no limit to what it
is that you can do but you also have
guys like gladiator gladiator is one of
the many allegories from Marvel Comics
this based on Superman oh you've got
Hyperion you've got Century you got a
handful of these guys but gladiator was
a guy who's strengthened his abilities
were relative to his confidence if he
was fighting a foe like The Incredible
Hulk and The Incredible Hulk just kept
getting stronger and stronger rather say
for example because he's fought and
defeated the Incredible Hulk before but
let's say we're talking about like world
breaker Hulk gladiator shows up on earth
in the midst of the world war hulk event
or something like that he starts getting
into a fight with world breaker Hulk and
world breaker Hulk he starts to
overpower him his confidence will start
to wane and when that happens his powers
will start to decrease so there's an out
for his character right there one of the
accusers I mean he's interesting enough
but he just got like a really strong
hammer is really all it is right the
real meat potatoes of this come down to
people like like beta ray bill who can
use Thor's hammer that's kind of a
caveat and he can he has his own in the
form of a storm breaker you've got
quasar wind along right and using the
quantum band I'm sorry that yeah the
quantum bands he can do stuff like open
open portals like wormholes and
space-time right so like teleport from
one side of the universe to the other if
I'm being honest I think the nega bands
are a lot more powerful in terms of what
they can do but these guys are by no
means anything to scoff at to give you
guys perspective if the annihilators
existed in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
during the events of Infinity Ward and
Avengers in game and they were even a
fraction of the power they had in Marvel
Comics they would have overpowered
Thanos so fast like it would not have
been any real contest whatsoever the
reality stone may have been enough in
order to kind of bend things in his
favor but when you're talking about guys
like Silver Surfer who can already
manipulate reality even if not on a
universal scale because in in Marvel
Comics the Silver Surfer is nowhere near
as powerful as the Infinity Gauntlet
right I mean there's a massive gap
between these two things but when you
talk about the Infinity Gauntlet in the
MCU versus Silver Surfer in the comics
then it becomes a whole different game
but the reality stone would be something
that could kind of bend reality sort of
trick then manipulate them a little bit
but in the end they'd be able to somehow
see through it right whether it was
wrong in the accuser whether it was
Wendel Vaughn using the quantum bands or
possibly even beta ray bill or Silver
Surfer
blood either in icon
really be able to do a whole lot in that
regard what you're talking about guys
who could overpower Thanos really see
past the illusions if we're talking
about a straight-up fight between Thanos
in the MCU and like the annihilators and
even all the forces of Thanos right so
like the coal obsidian so ebony maw
supergiant all that kind of stuff they
would get demolished like lunar of the
annihilators would just mop the floor
with them and that's what's so crazy
about this with a team this powerful
with a team this capable it can't work
and and it sucks to say that because I
mean you could scale them down right you
could scale the annihilators down in
power and make it like most everything
else in the MCU in which case they're
the annihilators in name only I mean
you're talking about it seem so powerful
Marvel into their story because I
couldn't make comics they couldn't make
compelling stories with them because
they could do pretty much anything you
scale that power level down you throw it
in the MCU it's a fraction of its
caliber counterpart and it's more or
less just a symbolic gesture right it's
just like hey you guys like the
annihilators and comics now they're in
the MCU they wouldn't really serve any
useful purpose because their useful
purpose was to be overpowered but the
fact that that useful purpose is gone
now means there is no real there is no
basis there is nothing really doing
there they're just guys who were there
and they can do some stuff cool story
bro and that's basically it so you can't
really put them in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and expect something compelling
to happen but it would be cool to see
right it is a cool concept and I would
love to see what kind of form it would
take later on down the road right but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end I know it's
kind of rambling right I know it's kind
of rambling going on but these two
powerful for the MCU videos these are my
videos these are my favorite videos we
just like ramble about why characters
and teams are just too Opie let me know
if you guys want to see a video on on
anti man Connor Sims let me know if you
guys want to see that I'm kind of
curious but if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]